yeah we think about content a lot and
and i don't i don't know if it is
my
uh
just my general interest in the creative
arts and media marketing
that's part of what i oversee at the pol
that has led to this ocd in a way of
production
um or if it's just knowing the path to
growing in our case a game is through
content and so
as athletes
you know part of what we're
known for is our attention to detail and
that usually comes out in practice i've
found with athletes who successfully
take the next um you know step in life
in business or media or whatever it is
that they choose to do
that that practice that work ethic
translates to other things so i try to
apply that same obsessiveness that i've
had for 24 years of playing lacrosse to
other things that i do
hmm i mean i was an athlete um
a really [ __ ] good one
um i saw that you went to indy 500 um
a couple of years ago uh i don't i don't
know if i have that same thing like i
like
i don't mind being on show and being on
but then when i come home
i hate people up in my space
you know i mean even you know
any money in the world that could afford
as many people to cook and clean and
take care of i wouldn't want that
because i don't like people up in my biz
meaning just in my space like i don't
care i'm an open book it's not a privacy
thing from that standpoint but just
do you ever get a little like i don't
know does it get old as i mean
i mean i wake up in the morning and the
camera's rolling in the red light and
then you're like man i just let me get
the sleepy eyes out of my eye before i
i'm exaggerating it's probably not that
intense but there's definitely a lot of
a lot of filming happening yeah i mean
our our origins are much different right
you
and what you're able to do to not only
racing but your
stature in the world of of sports and
media and business was so big pretty
quickly that the media that was coming
to you
was around the clock and probably
invasive
what
my relationship to media has been
through lacrosse which
was and is still considered by many a
niche sport
that when i graduated from college in
2008
the game wasn't even being distributed
on broadcaster cable television
and i had a facebook fan page that was
picking up tens of thousands of
followers organically and it kind of
tipped me off to
um you know to to to build or to create
a life in doing something that i loved i
needed to
build the media on my own
and so my relationship i think was
different from yours and its origin but
in the end yeah privacy is super
important i just think being a lacrosse
player versus one of the most famous
athletes uh of the last decade in your
case i can turn that on and off when i
want to more easily than you could huh
that's an interesting perspective yeah i
mean i'm going here because i think that
well first it was obvious to me that
there was that this you know you
are so
ingrained in the promotion of it in the
explaining of
lacrosse in
in and then also just i think you know
just to help people have someone to
cheer for like when i watch that video
of you being at the indy 500 i know that
colton herta knew who you were because
he's probably watched tons of your
videos like he played red cross and he
could follow you so he knew you well
um
and so but i think that the reason why
it's important is because this is what
gave you
it's
first and foremost it's what's giving
you the ability to promote lacrosse but
it's also probably what gave you the
idea to even start a league like the
fact that you had the vision
so
you know i know i'm kind of putting the
cart before the horse talking about all
the background of it and the videos and
promoting and the vision um before we
even talk about the league itself but i
think that that came first yeah i mean
it would be like if you were that's
needed totally if you
when you won your first indie card race
and that was such a big scene imagine
having done that in front of a quarter
of
the stands full and
no coverage across sportscenter
you would have been like okay this was
it doesn't displace the meaning for you
as an athlete like when i went won a
championship 10 years ago it feels like
the championship two years ago but we
care so much about what we do and we
know that other people
are just like us because you've met the
next young girls and boys that are
aspiring to be the next danica patrick
and i've met the next young girls and
boys that are aspiring to be the next
professional lacrosse player so they're
there they just didn't know how to
access the pro game in my case so
you know we learn as athletes along the
way through our sports sponsorship in
agency representation and pr and
learning how the teams in my case are
run and the league's run in your case
how the tours are being put together we
learn about the business there was a
need for me
based on how i'm ingrained to
to either amplify it or fix it
if i was an indycar racer i would never
even have thought to have done that
because the business was working right
and it was it would have been more about
okay how do i continue to grow so i had
this like complex
as professional lacrosse players like
damn what i'm doing is so much fun
fulfilling am i having to scrape the
bottom of a bit of the barrel for a
living yes but it shouldn't be this way
and i was seeing what the ufc did we're
seeing what f1 has done in the last
seven years we're seeing what you know
even like a lot of individual sports
that have continued to grow
um in team sports like the wnba it's
like the market is out there
and it's not this massive moat in the
90s where it was just football
basketball baseball
so i had no sports business experience i
knew how to build companies yeah because
it was
you know it was just applying
problem solving to
any scenario so a lot of like reading
and researching and networking and
asking questions but i knew it was out
there and to your point
when we were creating media through our
social channels originally was just to
talk to our fans
and then it became like oh damn through
the comment section and other things
like people really like lacrosse how do
i how do i then help it become better
so
where did this
business mind come from i mean
or capability even
yeah i think that it came from really
two areas one is
when i was out of school um the rookie
wage that i signed for was like 6 500
bucks and then
you know
sorry a year yeah for the season yeah it
was brutal like we were can't even live
on that that's not even minimum wage no
it's not and i had a uh i had a job at
the time with a real estate company i
was a
an analyst kind of like back my way into
a job because that's what
a lot of athletes who even playing
division one at their highest level if
there's not a pro game then you move on
to the workforce it's like the
enterprise commercials are always
pitching on like athletes going into the
next stage of their life when there's
nothing else to to take the next step
and that's how lacrosse was um but i was
like
you know figuring out how to
pursue being what i wanted to be at the
time was the best player in the world
and one of the best to ever play
we had world championships every four
years so i was training my ass off but
also
to point number one trying to figure out
how to get a reasonable wage
and so
yeah part two is
all right well if you if you're known in
your sport what are some ways you can
make extra money well through
appearances through endorsements and
then through what i was running at the
time a camp in clinic business so i was
basically traveling the country teaching
kids and families and coaches lacrosse
and then you know picking up
registration fees from it so i was
[ __ ] scrapping like doing [ __ ] that
like i bet you and i don't really want
to do because it's pretty humbling to
like
travel to indianapolis with a bag and
like some lacrosse pennies and work with
like 150 kids and like
you know
uh stay at a like a a pretty like you
know
a grimy hotel and like try to like have
nice margins and
so i was learning the principles of
business by necessity and then i would
pick up everything along the way
with my under armour sponsorship and
then a red bull sponsorship because i
got access to stuff that other athletes
at the highest level were doing i was
going oh this is what it could look like
well i mean endorsements and showing up
and getting paid for things tends to be
a lot easier yeah when
the sport is bigger and the name is big
you know what i mean like that so like
as that being a way to make money it's
also still not easy when the the
the eyes aren't on what you're doing as
much so
you know teaching kids is probably
you know definitely a lot of a lot of
that time yeah yeah i mean there's a ton
of time
but i had to think about things like
marketing my camp business and um you
know building an llc to protect myself
legally and taking out insurance on
fields and
customer service with parents who wanted
to cancel the day before because their
kid got injured and like all that [ __ ]
was running through
my
um
small company at the time and i hired an
assistant
and uh and was figuring it out but on
the sponsorship side i know from
speaking to different brand managers
i've worked with
they uh it was because of that curiosity
was also you know when you get
when you're constantly
you know a second or third tier athlete
and this is just to give people are
listening
how like either closer if they're
younger and listening how uh how long it
felt away but it feels close to you and
i was 2008 to like 2011 or 12.
um and that was that was when people
were just like there's professional
lacrosse that exists and
um and like who is this guy and so you
you build thicker skin
so i was probably a little bit
more
um
maybe ambitious and uh
and almost like negligent in the way
that i would work with my brand partners
and ask them for approval on like
marketing assets and like oh who is the
photographer who's the videographer how
are we shooting this can i look at the
storyboard and i was always kind of
interested in that side of the business
and maybe it was because i never thought
that i'd be able to make it too long in
professional lacrosse so what i was
going to do next but all of those bits
and pieces were now a part of what i do
today with the pol because it's
running a league there's so many
aspects to it